looking Southwest and you can see the
skies are clear nice blue sky and
temperatures are a mix of 70s some low
80s mostly 70s though and it feels great
because the humidity is low we've got
60s up there at Kyle Canyon but remember
there are heat advisories posted for the
mountains while we've got heat warnings
that start tomorrow morning for all the
lower elevations of Southern Nevada
Northwest Arizona southeast California
Saturday morning all the way through
Monday evening with one teens up to 115
for the valley
and in the mountains up to near 90
degrees that's Kyle Canyon while Lee
Canyon we'll be looking at upper 70s
today to near 80 by Sunday so that's
pretty warm for the mountains when
normally they'd have low 70s for highs
so we're definitely well above normal up
in the mountains as well 110 for the
lake Southwest breezes maybe two 25
miles an hour today it's gonna make the
waters pretty choppy please please wear
your life jackets put them on the little
ones you can borrow them there a
lifeguard I mean there are Ranger
stations three of them out there that
you can just borrow lifejackets no
reason not to have life jackets on 112
tomorrow 113 Sunday almost the record of
114 and 111 on Monday look at these
morning's near 90 degrees for morning
lows way way too hot for the Simon July